going to be honest enough to tell you that I'm worried about America. I'm worried about
our nation because it's sick with racism still. Just think about the fact that we live
in a nation which was founded on the principle that all men are created equal. And yet men
are still arguing over whether the color of a man's skin determines the content of his character.
And I believe that the Lord told me to say to the United States of America that it's sick with
militarism and it's sick with excessive materialism. Have you ever thought about it? They are
between 38 and 50 million people in the United States of America who are poverty-stricken,
making income less than the poverty level. And yet this is the richest nation in the history of
the world. Our national growth product this year will go beyond 800 billion dollars.
And yet there between 38 and 50 million people who are poverty-stricken, and I'm wrong. A lot of
people are afraid to say it. But I don't mind saying that you see somebody said to me last night,
don't you think Dr. King, you are going to have to start speaking more in terms of the administration's
policy because since you started talking against a Warren Vietnam, it's hurt the budget of your
organization and people who once respected you don't respect you anymore. And I had to look over
and say, so I'm sorry, but you don't know me. I'm not a consensus leader. I don't determine what
is right and wrong by looking at the budget of my organization. And I don't determine what is
right and wrong by taking a gallop hole of the majority opinion. And so because there's something wrong,
our struggle must continue. And what we must see is that our nation's summers of riots
are caused by our nation's winters of delay.